the Joe Rogan experience huh so I think
I don't think they want to form a
relationship with us I think they're
coming and going like taxis and they
have been since the beginning of the
existence of life on this planet of the
existence of this planet do you think
they engineered human beings
well that mission to Mars movie is one
of NASA employees favorite movies I
think maybe the motion of Mars movement
that's a mission to Mars Tim Robbins
really good picture doc it's a features
of the future yeah mission to Mars yeah
what's it about it's about the mission
to Mars and them discovering that was a
civilization there and that perhaps we
were helped along in our development but
you resists around ah I'm not sure
mission to houses really really good it
was like a horror movie here's the
here's the yeah I saw that movie there's
a case for interplanetary saucers that
was in Life magazine I can't remember
this movie now was that a good movie it
was really good in the end Tim Robbins
kind of this few astronauts that got
really deep into UFOs right as literal
Adam is one of them I'll have an
interesting story for you and this is of
course totally anecdotally part of the
it's part of the lore and we have you
want another drink
hell yeah okay so Neil Armstrong and
Buzz Aldrin I do believe that we
actually rent to the moon III don't
believe that I don't believe that that's
a fake experience I know I'm gonna said
people say oh well it was black and the
dustin's you know they just flew up and
it wouldn't it wouldn't crystal had
vodka queenís vodka on the planet so I
believe the one and and and and you're
live Buzz Aldrin a good friend of mine
loved as a good friend of everybody's
but I love Buzz and so they go to the
moon and I love that story about there
was only 17 seconds of fuel left one
thing when they landed and then that he
had to kind of hop over some rocks to
get there you know so there's a story
that Neil Armstrong was at a conference
in in in France in a hotel room and one
and there was a woman there who had been
previously head of mi6 and she was a
part of this cocktail party
and she overheard a conversation between
Neil Armstrong and another gentleman was
in the intelligence service and I was
asking him about the moon landing and
Neil said you know there was a frequency
that we switched to to talk about other
things that were happening at that time
and the guy said what do you mean he
said when we landed there on the rim of
the crater nearby he said there were
several ships and they were large and
menacing
what's a menacing ship shaped like one
of your bottles of skulls well no no
this is a happy skull no the Coneheads
starship her mother gone has so I mean
that's a total ending I mean but I think
you know if that if you deal arm if
that's true you know well well he only
said that one time in French maybe they
again a woman you want this opens we'll
have a straight right the woman the
woman was with mi6 purportedly that's
kind of a neat story of course it's a
neat story Edgar Mitchell said that he
saw something out there too right you're
Mitchell did and he's passed Condon he's
passed away since right yeah although he
was a firm believer and the and then the
STS 1979 STS Space Shuttle footage
you've seen that STS 1979 tether
satellite tether break oh I have seen
yeah the tether broke off it was a mile
long and they were supposed to spin off
a satellite it was a mile long and they
stand that broke so then Heather is a
mile long but in the back of the tether
you see these old lifesaver shaped rings
going back and forth mm-hmm well David
Cerreta says that's the species that was
trying to help the planet and they were
bringing giant water bags and giant
giant water vessels to heal our ozone
layer it was a STS 1979 space shuttle
tether water heals ozone layers are
these what water yeah water and water -
it's a big big massive massive dumps of
water these were supposed to be these
old shaped lifesaver shaped UFO figures
and then what he did was he compared
them against the length of the tether
which was a mile long and said these
things would have had
and you know quite large now that's
David Sarita you should have amantes is
a brilliant ufologist and theorist hmm
and STS space-shuttle 1979 and then
Lonnie Zamora you should also check and
herb Shermer a Chir Mir I'm Leslie Kean
and ralph Blumenthal you know this is a
piece of paper but there's a video for
there you go evidence records and
plasmids in the thermosphere there we go
they're ten separate NASA space shuttle
missions over two hundred miles above
the earth within the the thermosphere
the structures appear to be
self-illuminated maybe several meters or
kilometers in size and have four
distinct morphologies what is this
what's the title of this whose is from
emeritus brain research laboratory
northern california cosmology it's
pretty neat it may be wrong Joseph's PhD
Center for cosmology Silicon Valley
California huh the there is video video
the tether the video is weird and
someone described it as ice crystals and
they said the perspective is what's
screwing everybody up as if the ice
crystals are between us and the cable
but it makes it look like they're
enormous but they're actually quite
small I think I think at this point we
can accept that these ships are real
that they're advanced there we yes we
can I think we can accept that there's
just so many so much so much footage so
many reports Ted Phillips has trace
evidence so many landing sites so many I
think we'd accept they're real I think
we accept these beings are real there
are many different species some are
benevolent to a summer malevolent what
we have to get past is okay now that we
know that how will that help human
transformation now John Mac at this
session I was at at this Fifth Avenue
Medical Institute a woman got up and she
said I was a socialite in Massachusetts
I all I cared about was money and
spending money and where I could go and
spend money and and buying things and
one afternoon I was in my garden and an
orange orb came into the garden and a
figure got out and lectured me you have
so much power just like the guy in the
sailboat you can make this planet a
better place your obligation now is to
use your power and your wealth to make
this planet a better place and she is
now one of the leading in
mentalists on the planet sheep devotes
her money and time to this what's her
name I don't know her name ember her
name but Jen Harz and I Jan Hara and I
do know his name he's head of MUFON and
why is Jan Harz on an IBM X IBM
mainframe engineer a head of new font
because when he was a boy in Marin
County California he and his brother
were left for the weekend he's 10 and 12
year old brother 12 year old brother and
he was 10
an orange orb dropped into his backyard
and two beings got out and played with
them for several hours and then he came
back the next day and John said I have
to go into science I got to know what
that was that wasn't a helicopter that
wasn't have you had Jan on if you had
yeah yeah I have Jan on and you should
have okay you should have Jan on you
should have Beverly trout on she's the
she's the Midwestern one of the
directors for mid at the Midwest Sam
moranto the expert on the Tinley Park
cases which that is so great I want you
to attack right has no notes in front of
them these notes are these words just
flying out of his head these names of
beastly grain dismembered Tinley Park I
mean two Delta's parking above your
family barbecue you know so it's
entertaining we got to get past that
they exist and get to the point though
how do we benefit our planet how do we
make this planet better how do we take
these warnings The Day the Earth Stood
Still well the greatest UFO movies ever
oh yeah he comes down and he says you
know these nuclear toys you're playing
with we don't we don't like that you
know so I think that there's some
intervention to Barada nikto
Klaatu Barada nikto Patricia Neal not
sure what a great movie man that's an
inaugural movie yeah it was that have
you shown your children no not yet you
should show yeah that was in the 50s
yeah that's a great one
and because it really took the real
science of what was going on and and and
it took all of the stories that were
reported in Bruce's book here and kind
of distilled them into you know into a
theory of what might be happening
[Applause]